okay good morning everyone
um we have a few subs today so
thanks for
sitting in and welcome to children and
family law
and the first we're gonna i'm gonna open
the exact session
on um sb 336
uh representative nelson do you have a
motion
do we have a second
denise seconds
i'm sorry not denise jeepers
representative smith seconds
representative nelson
is there any discussion
yes i'm sorry i asked a question i can't
hear you good morning madam cheer
could people just introduce themselves
unfortunately
i wasn't here last term and i don't know
everyone
that's sitting in oh sure thank you can
we finish this exact session first since
we've already started it
um
okay so the motion on the floor is ought
to pat on the emotion is ought to pass
on
sb 336 is there any discussion
would you like would you like to speak
to your most motion representative
nelson
she doesn't think so anybody else
all right then i'll have the clerk call
the roll
representative disimon
yes
representative yokela yes
representative nelson yes
representative belanger yes
representative johnson
yes representative mcdonald yes
representative smith
representative long yes representative
alice sayer yes
representative grossman
yes representative levesque yes
representative murray yes
representative altula is absent
representative petrino i will be voting
yes madam chair rice yes
motion carries 14 to 0.
can you pass that to representative
nelson
i'm in committee so i'm going to have to
okay
up next is
b
326 i'll wait for you to be ready just
oh i missed the first one oh well we'll
are you ready
all right
okay so
oh first of all i'm going to ask the
subs to please introduce themselves
because not everyone here knows who
everyone is
so we'll start with uh representative
murray
hi thank you for having me madam chair
my name is megan murray my home
committee is environment and agriculture
so i'm happy to be here thank you thank
you
representative johnson representative
don johnson from laconia
and
that's it and i'm usually in commerce
and commissions
representative mcdonald
good morning everyone i'm wayne mcdonald
i represent the town of londonderry and
i'm usually on the election law
committee on vice chairman
thank you
okay
up next i said 326 right uh
representative yokela
second seconded by representative
belanger
their discussion would you like to speak
to your motion representative yokela
i mean
from the testimony um
i believe that this
um work
can be had without the study commission
and so i don't believe that it's
necessary and so that's why
we should oppose the
bill thank you
further discussion representative long
thank you madam chair um
yeah there there was
all the early learning childhood centers
the kids counts they were all in favor
of this
evidently there's a grant
for the office of early childhood i got
here uh so i think
i think this is a follow-up to a
grant to put this bill together or to
put this idea together
i i think it's a great idea it covers
people from birth to eight which a lot
of it covers birth to five i believe or
six
uh so i thought the birth to eight was
good cover birth to five is what it is
what child care normally covers um so i
i i feel it's a um
you know i i feel it's a good bill and
uh
as far as finance i don't let them
decide whether they want to fund it or
not or how much to fund it so
i'm going to be supporting uh i'm going
to be opposed to that about to pass
thank you
representative grossman
thank you madam chair
um
so i just want to point out that this is
a bipartisan issue early childhood um
and these early years are incredibly
research has shown that there's a
significant return on investment for
these years and there is a cost savings
there
and i can attest to being a parent of a
child with special needs that
those early years are so significant
into capturing
a disability
and helping a child to get on track
potentially so that they can participate
in their school district um
so
we did see a lot of support for this um
and i'll be supporting it thank you
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and just to hear
from the testimony um
my concern and while his fiscal's job
maybe not necessarily ours and more at a
policy standpoint but the biggest issue
that i had with this was that there's a
fiscal note but that they're not asking
for
anything it just seemed very confusing
so for me it was more form looking for
clarification and nobody could provide
that which is why i'm supporting motion
itl
seeing none we'll have the clerk call
on sb 326
representative desimone yes
representative yokela yes
representative nelson yes
representative belanger yes
representative johnson
yes
representative macdonald yes
representative smith
representative long no
yes
no
representative levesque no
representative murray
no
representative alicea is not here
representing she's right there i
apologize
where are you
oh i meant actually i apologize i meant
to say all chiller
my apologies and representative petrino
i will be voting no
madam chair rice
we have nine
voting yes
and five voting
no
okay
here let me
do you have some over there or do i need
to give him one of these
okay
and we'll do 144 next just so you can
get i'm i'm sorry i'm all i'm on
ready
all right
um so next up is sb 144
representative nelson do you have a
motion
thank you madam chair yes i do uh my
is there a second second seconded by
representative nelson would you like to
speak to your motion
i would thank you um of concern
to me is
based um the enrollment-based billing
should continue unless a child exceeds
two weeks of consecutive absence from
the program without notification to the
provider regarding circumstances and
agreed upon return date i feel like this
framework could allow for children to be
absent several times a week and still be
enrolled in the program
causing unnecessary costs to the program
and possibly preventing space for
another child who is in need of care
further discussion
representative long
thank you madam chair uh
yeah
this is
this is a bipartisan child care
scholarship
i
i'm not following the uh being absent
multiple times
a week
and still
using the reimbursement
i like the enrolled base reimbursements
that's why they have the two weeks
and um
i think this is a way past it's due and
i'm
going to oppose the itl thank you madam
chair thank you
and and i'll just say that
i do wish that it wasn't two consecutive
weeks because i am very concerned
that
people can keep their child children
home twice a week
and there's there's no repercussion it
has to be two full weeks and so by
keeping you know they could keep them
home three days a week and we're still
paying for it
and there's there's no you know
no repercussions to that there has to be
accountability
and that's really my only issue
with this
is that i'm just concerned i'm worried
about it being abused when when in
reality like was said there could be
another child that would be there five
days a week
and they're being they're losing that
spot because someone is you know
technically only sending their kids
twice a week but but
being paid for the full week that's
that's my issue with it
thank you madam chair
um
i i just want to speak to the concern
that you're having and that's a valid
concern that somehow
the spot would be lost um
but there is absolutely nothing in this
bill that a la that does it that says
that um child care providers who
very very much
want to serve their communities i hear
from
um three in my area uh that they have
wait lists
they have absolutely incredibly long
weight lifts and
they
i think that very very
small and very small
possibility
of potential
abuse and it is it is a small
possibility of potential it's so far out
there
abuse
um is
does not weigh equally
to
the wait lists that exist now
and the families who desperately need
this service right now
and um the you know the
overwhelming reason that
parents
are looking for
quality affordable
sustainable uh child care
is that they work
and
they're not they're they are looking to
have a place where their child will be
cared for
um and
learning while they're there in a safe
environment so that they can go to work
that this is not
this is child care this is not
babysitting so that you can go out to
dinner and this is not somewhere to put
your child so that you can go play
tennis
this these these are working families
who are struggling
um and
this particular
bill has an eligibility
um which is only 250 percent of poverty
level
so this isn't this is not a a pla i
don't see this bill as being something
that is
inviting
the kind of
overt fraud that
is um
being suggested i didn't use the word
fraud i i am extrapolating from the
the phrase that you use keep their kids
home for three weeks
i didn't say three weeks i said two to
three weeks i said two to three days a
week two to three days a week okay
okay
and and just so you see where i'm coming
from is i have worked in a child care
facility before and i've seen this i've
seen it where parents
will say they're bringing their kid the
full week and only bring them three days
a week
or bring them two days a week right and
and
when we knew we had other
parents out there that needed this but
we were already obligated to this spot
that's all i'm saying and i don't
want people to not be able to afford
child care
i just want to make sure we have people
using it that
are going to
use it always rather than a two-week
span of being out consecutively before
be booted from the program
representative long
thank you madam chair um so this this is
a three-month pilot program
uh which includes a report filed
september 1st 2022
uh which includes the absentee rate so
it's a three-month pilot program let's
let's look at the absentee rate is what
they're asking for
so i you know i
i
i agree that
parents may do that hold their kids on
when i had my son for the week
uh i
i kept the moon um you know uh so so
it's a pilot program
it it has it has some uh absolute
um
intent on moving forward with the
scholarship program
and in three months you could review the
absentee rate and we could adjust it in
three months or or actually it's uh
dhhs um
[Music]
you know could could make some
recommendations uh
you know before they continue it or they
may say this is not working so
you know it's a three-month attempt i i
don't see where that could hurt okay
representative de simone
thank you madam chair
considering that i have
two grandchildren who
were
i know that
in both cases
when
one particular child care facility or
another was looked into
the statement from the
childcare
was
well
we have somebody who doesn't bring their
children
any more than one or two days a week but
they've paid for the full week so we
cannot give you a slot
until they no longer pay for that full
week
with a scholarship program
the scholarship will pay for the whole
week so you do have
children
who are in dire need of child
care three
maybe four days a week
and because the scholarship is
paying for all those days the child care
facility has no alternative but to keep
that slot
for the child who's not
attending and that scares me that
the state would be paying
for a service
that is not being given to a child in
need
thank you
representative all chiller
thank you very much thank you for the
opportunity to clarify some of my
earlier statements and i want to
i want to begin by reiterating what
representative long said is that what we
are debating right now we are debating a
a
a pilot program
um and this pilot program would
essentially be running through the
summer which is a an incredibly
difficult time for families to find
child care because we
we know well school is not in session
now we also know because we heard and i
am going to base all of my
um statements right now on the actual
testimony we heard
i have my own experiences as does
everyone most of the people here
which our brings our biases to the table
but if we look just at the
bless you
at the
testimony that we heard
we heard
from the bureau of child development and
collaboration
that the ccdf is under utilized
so
the ccdf the child care development fund
discretionary funds are being under
utilized and this is a pilot program to
see if perhaps the way we approach child
care in the state of new hampshire
could use a tweaking could use a new
method could use some fresh eyes and we
have
ccdf money
to allow us the flexibility
to look at that
that one of the challenges
um we heard this from the earl from
early learning new hampshire that they
have identified
that the challenge
for us is that the government recommends
based versus attendance base
typical policy as they as was brought
into testimony is if you are enrolled
you pay whether you attend or not
and this pr this program
ensures that
parents particularly now who are
struggling with
having children in and out of school
because of covet exposures having covert
exposures themselves
that they get to keep their slot and the
child care facility doesn't lose income
that is a bonus and what we heard
is that putting enrollment-based
billing in place is a form of primary
prevention and we heard this
from rebecca watkowski the policy
director at new futures and during the
pandemic
new hampshire actually used this model
to stabilize our child care industry
and we heard from child care providers
when
that money was being debated
that they really really really needed
the help
so
um i would
i would urge my colleagues
to give this pilot program a chance to
use the money that we have been given
from arbor the american rescue plan
money
has
dedicated funds in it
for child care and development funds
like they are specific to this purpose
we are not pulling money out of general
care funds we are not pulling money away
from another program that the state of
new hampshire has already committed to
funding
we have the money to do exactly this
kind of work
and i would i would urge us to not
make the mistake of leaving federal
funds on the table
and not use them for the purposes of
which they were intended and give us a
chance to get some
heart some more hard data thank you
all right seeing none i'll have the
on sb 144
representative disimon
representative yokela yes
representative nelson
representative belanger yes
representative johnson
yes
representative mcdonald
representative smith
representative long no
representative alice sayer
representative grossman
representative murray
no
representative all chiller
representative petrino i'll be voting no
madam chair rice
yes
all right
you ready
all right next we'll take up sp 457
representative belanger do you have a
motion
yes madam chair i move itl
on sb 457 okay second
second
seconded by representative d simone
thank you sorry i was just trying to
refresh my brain as i'm
i don't have my typical stuff so uh my
issue with this bill was um while i
understand
full-heartedly that
some of these non-profits might be
losing their umbrella policies and that
is unfortunate
um and
in respect to uh
actually had a conversation with
somebody the other day about this and
that if we lose the iso foster care
providers it's a problem
but i don't necessarily think this is
the best solution
and establishing a commission is just
it's just kind of not something i want
to do at this time so that's why i
support the itl motion and we'll be
working with the department of insurance
okay seeing none i'll have the clerk
457 itl
representative
on the motion of itl i vote yes
representative yokela
yes
representative nelson yes representative
belanger yes
representative johnson
yes representative macdonald yes
representative smith yes
representative long no
representative alicea no representative
grossman
no representative levesque
no representative murray
no representative all chiller
no representative petrino i'll be voting
no madam chair rice yes
representative long are you gonna do a
minority report
you're not
okay
up next is
sb 431
representative yokela do you have a
motion yes ought to pass
do i have a second all second
representative yokela
yes i'd like to move uh amendment uh
2022-1465-h
would you like to speak to your
amendment
can i get a second part of it i want to
i'll second
the uh
motion for an amendment
and then you can speak to your amendment
thank you just let everybody get it
uh so there was a bunch of uh
[Laughter]
i'm looking around and i still could
um so uh
a couple of things that changed is that
um
that uh the judge just needs to
decide that
this the use of this the formula is in
the best interests of the child
and there was also
some
concern about
the
the language as far as finding out like
the extracurricular activities
um
and whether or not the they should be
going back to the court to
um
to
those to um kind of get adjustments for
those
um amended uh
optional
expenses
and so
um
while
well uh the cr the law allows for them
to make adjustments as far as
um
because of those
uh
because of
allocation of day care school programs
vacation and summer care
um
it's just said that the the court should
um allocate
allocate those and not get into
um
you know
uh or anything else kind of a thing uh
it was an open-ended uh statement as far
as like what else it could be
uh
like the court could be diving into as
far as
um these uh um additional
costs of
of
variable expenses
and
so then there was
um
definitely about um
or 1647 as far as the one point the
increase of available money
um which was not in this bill um there
was no increase of funds it was just
reallocating the funds and so
um
on line
uh determine
what the
heck
i've i've fixed this amendment i think
this is not the amendment that is
correct
well i have the amendment already i just
need to print it
and i sent i think i sent it to the
whole committee i just
um
i went upstairs to look at see if they
got printed
and it looks like it didn't and so i
so what i was speaking to
was an amendment that's not here like
this doesn't increase the funds so we're
going to take a 15-minute break so you
can get copies of the actual amendment
yeah
cope with lockdown yeah they can't come
in here you can't go in here right now
normally
they're back
sorry
okay okay everybody
let's bring it back bring it back in
okay
so everyone has
the correct amendment uh is it two zero
two two one five seven five h
okay that's the correct amendment that
representative yokola will be speaking
to
i will withdraw the other motion uh
i will withdraw my second
from the first amendment and i will
second
amendment 1575-h
thank you so what i was trying to get to
was on line uh
26 27 where
the current
language does not increase the parental
support obligations and we have heard
both from the carson study and
even from the people that made the bill
originally that they want that um it
cost
more to have two households and so
um
what this seeks to do is
um the carson study just said um a
hundred and uh multiplied by 150 but i'm
just suggesting that we at least go up
to 120
of what the current support obligation
would be for the additional cost of
having two households and so
if um so this would be
meaning that there's more money
for um getting attributed to the
parental support obligation um
to to support the kids uh
um and that's what line 26 and 27 does
um as far as
as far as that so that's one um thing
that was not currently in the bill
um and and also
um just
uh you know that there
was
you know going from
only being
so what the bill did before was it tied
the hands of the judge so that he had to
make a whole bunch of findings to uh
to be able to make this offset and so
what i'm just saying is that um instead
of making all of those findings that he
just makes the finding that it's in the
best interest of the child and then
online um
uh
so and then and then we reiterate that
on line 31 and 32 of this amendment
which says if the difference if the net
the net
the difference method is not in the best
interest of the child the court may
order child support guideline amount or
another amount that is in the best
interest of the child so really we're
just getting to what is in the best
interest of the child
make that the amount that we need to pay
if that if the judge finds that you know
whatever the calculation is
and this that language was in the
original bill is that i didn't i didn't
make up that language but we're i'm just
saying what the
the court needs to say you know we
we took everything into consideration we
said this is in the best interest of the
child and we are suggesting a formula
but we are not holding that court to
that formula if it's not in the best
interest of the child is what this bill
does and so that's why i hope you will
support this amendment um and so thank
further discussion
representative de simone
thank you madam chair
um
representative yokela and i went over
the original bill
extensively
with the thought of what's in the best
interest of the child
and how is the child gonna monetarily
benefit
from the original bill and this
amendment the changes that
representative yokela has made
which represent this
amendment
clearly means that in the end the child
reaps the benefit
it takes the child's best interest
first and foremost
and that's why i
uh support this amendment
so
right out of the gate
um
just throws it all out the window so
if the nap difference method is not in
the best interest of the child like
we're the whole point is to set up
a formula
that will benefit
the children or child
living in two spaces
and living um
integrating two parts of their life
into into
a you know trying to to build
healed over a fracture
and um
we are trying to create
a rubric
so that
the children are centered
in this process
not the parents
and um
we need to leave space
and i don't i'm finding this
particular amendment hard to follow
i
don't understand why the
the final
uh
phrasing
essentially negates everything prior to
it
um
so if i may i just in the original bill
that that same exact language is on line
15 and 16 of page 2.
that same exact language
i understand that but it's also
after that language
there are
there are a series of
considerations that the court can
consider
and i'm noticing in
representative yokela's amendment
that in lines
17 18 and 19 when child support is
adjusted
a modification from the original bill
the court shall
allocate the cost of day care after
school programs vacation and summer care
unless the parties have agreed to an
allocation of these expenses so what
what this says to me is that the court
is now
shall now going to have to get involved
with what the actual costs of daycare
are
in the specific
geographical area that that
these parents live in and they may not
be in the same geographical area the
court is going to have to get involved
with
you know asking for
affidavits attesting to what after
school programs there are how much they
cost
how much summer camp costs and so on and
so forth and what what the court is this
is setting up
um is that you know any parent that
wants to sign their kid up
for an after-school program is going to
have to go to court
for
the permission to unless it's been
previously granted and then if they if
the money
isn't enough
um they're going to have to then go back
to court for those those at that extra
sign up fee at this
changing shell
really really really puts some um
stringent
bumpers on this that
it leaves it leaves no flexibility for
the court whatsoever and actually why
would the court want to be involved in
those kinds of things isn't the whole
point that we're trying to equalize
the child's um standard of living so
that we don't have to go to court every
time we want to sign up for soccer camp
and we don't have to go to court because
children are in two different daycares
it was that shall intentional
representative leo kelly i guess that's
what my question boils down to
i'm wondering are you confused when you
read the original bill because that
language is not changed in my amendment
that language precisely matches like
line r uh page two line three to five th
that exact wording is in the original
build so you're saying that the
amendment is confusing and maybe maybe
you're also confused about the original
bill and so maybe um you don't support
the original bill and so i guess do you
have an uh amended language that affect
that fixes the language on uh line page
two line three to five that you that you
had issues with in the original bill
well i i appreciate you
inquiring into my understanding of the
original bill and i do understand thank
you
um but your shell
is after an elimination
of almost entire the entire page one of
so
so i didn't add that language that
language is in the current bill so i
don't understand how that language is
i guess that is my my
question
um
so that that language is not changing so
i i can't i didn't write the la that
language i didn't so i can't comment on
okay
representative long
thank you madam chair so just for
clarification the amendment replaces
uh
section one
can you give line numbers that you're
yeah that all of section all of the
first page
through uh line five
on page two
through line five on page two
so
the
so the amendment replaces section one of
the bill so it would replace everything
through line 20
all the way from line one on the first
page to line 20 on the second page and
the and then line 22 23 24 25 26 or 25
would all stay the same and so this
would be replace that uh section one of
the bill
so it replaces everything
on page two to
line 20 is what it replaces
and then 21 right through 25
that's what section 1 is and then
16 years and i didn't realize there was
a section two or a one
um
all right so so
i'm correct right
one replaces through
page two line 20.
this amendment replaces that
yes second section one yep
i mean i can give you kind of um
kind of uh a rundown of which
which language is in which part on the
original bill i guess if that would help
but
if you're trying to
nope
no i get it i'm just
i'm just trying to look to see what was
the deleted
so
so um 18 19 and 20 are on the back side
of this page is the new roman numeral
this
um
is
okay representative altschiller you had
a question
or statement
yes i have a couple of questions so i
want to acknowledge that yes
the language in lines 31 and 32 of the
amendment um
are in the original bill which is part
nine
and my objection is that
the the amendment
the rose out
a whole bunch of stuff that we had
specifically put in
to
that we're specifically there
for the best interest of the children
um so the phrase
doesn't apply in the same way
let me explain
for instance
in the original bill on lines 21 22 and
if with an adjustment the lower earning
parent is not able to meet the need
meet the cost of child raising in a
similar or approximately equal style to
that of the other parent the court shall
um
that
is not reflected in this amendment and
to take the
would be setting up one parent for
failure
which is detrimental to the child
and
should not we supporting
parents
in order to keep the child's best
interest
i i am still
i am still struggling with and maybe
you can help me understand why
it was important to
remove parts two
three and four out of the original bill
go ahead
i think she was asking that was a
question um
so
their
um
line 18 to 23 um
did on the original
bill
m tied the hands of the judges to to not
just consider the best interest of the
child and so in the example that you
were saying on line 21 they are forced
to do something which they may determine
is not in the best interest of the child
and so what i'm saying is
stop we need to not tie the hands of the
judges that if they determine that this
is in the best interest of the child
then they should be able to make empower
the judges to say this is in the best
interest of the child this is the money
that i'm going to
going to uh require and not go
um follow these rigid rules that don't
allow for flexibility when they are
making that judgment and so i think that
that um that uh
that both
uh
the line eight eight to 23
um
on the original bill
and um
the requirement
that
they online 15 16 and 17 on page two
only let them do what is in the best
interest of the child in certain cases
and so what i'm saying is let's let the
judges do what's in the best issues of
the child in all the cases those are
that's
what i'm trying to do with this
representative all chiller
thank you i think i'm beginning to
understand um
i think i'm going to understand some of
what you're saying
um
what what i'm
what i'm struggling with here if i heard
you correctly
on the original bill
lines 17 18 19 20
if i heard you correctly did you just
said that those are not in the best
interest of the child
um and i would
i would that is that what you just said
that those
so the language on line 11 is saying
it's in the best interest of the child
so it's on the original bill thank you
on the original bill it says if it's in
the best interest of the child and
then we're going to keep on deciding
stuff and so if it's in the best
interest of the child but not
doing um line
12 through
then the judge's hands are tied and they
cannot order that judgment
even though they determined on line
seven and eleven they said it isn't the
best insures a child and so why are we
limiting judges to to say no you you
have to find it's in the best interest
of the child and other things five other
things seven other things whether that
list be one thing or a hundred other
things i don't i don't um think that
that's um
that what we need to be focused on is
what is in the best interest of the
child if the judge determines that and
we have a bunch of of things both in the
parenting plan um
that he should be considering when he's
considering the best interest of the
child
um that is
i think we
say what is in the best interest of the
child full stop
we don't have additional qualifiers i in
in some of the cases maybe those things
are part of the best interests of the
child but then it would be covered by
that best interest of the child if it's
not if those things being considered are
not in the best interest of the child
then the judge has the flexibility to
not consider them so that is what i'm
saying
so representative yokela along that that
where where is the best interest of the
it's not
so in the original bill
they don't define it in there either but
on lines
through 13
when we're talking about the adjust the
adjustment
shall be based on
the the court's
the adjustment of support
shall be based on written findings by
the court
or by agreement of the parties that the
adjustment is in the best interest of
the child
and
the adjustment of the income of the
lower earning parent enables that parent
to meet the costs
of child rearing
so
it would seem that taking that out
removes um
removes
you know a
a standard you know a living standard
for both houses if we want to if we are
if we are and it seems that with this
bill we are looking to
we are we're looking to create similar
living situations for each child so that
one child would not be
either living in poverty poverty or on
the brink of poverty
and one child you know living
extremely comfortably
this amendment that you've brought
forward throws that possibility out all
um is about best interest of the child
but
the amendment allows for
best interest of the child to be
at the judicial discretion of whatever
judge is sitting on the bench at that
moment and what we've done in the
original bill is to provide some
parameters saying that you sh that you
may
and so
please do you may consider the adequacy
of housing accommodations you may
consider access to nutrition you may
consider transportation if one
parent has a car and the other parent
does not have reliable transportation
you may consider access to technology
these are all things on line 17 that you
know if one parent is not able to afford
to have
[Music]
a reliable
broadband hookup at their house that
severely impacts how that child will be
able to access educational materials
particularly if they have to be homesick
or if we have
another response to a public health
crisis
so
it doesn't seem like the best interest
of the child is being addressed in the
amendment
so much as the comfort level of the
parents
and
what we're trying to avoid is setting
representative belanger
thank you madam chair and um
i appreciate the representative from
fremont my neighbor
for bringing forward this amendment one
thing and it's a common misconception
child support is not supposed to be used
to support the other parent
and we see time and time again
that that it's abused
and i have personal experience of child
support being abused
my mother abused the child support
from my father
and there were other underlying issues
there but
we
this best interest of the child uh is
not in the previous bill and is not in
the amendment so we're talking about
something that's
really not relevant
um
and uh i really think we need to get to
uh get get back to the basics here um
one parent
should not be
supporting two households the purpose of
child support is to support the child
not the other parent
and the premise
that child support should be used to
support the other child is absolutely
ridiculous and we should the other
parent thank you sorry
to support the other parent is
absolutely ridiculous and um this bill
does everything this amendment excuse me
does everything that we need to do
to um support the child and not the
representative long
thank you madam chair
so
uh
we have a child support study going on
that'll
go through 12 22 i believe so that'll be
forthcoming
uh with respect to getting rid of other
things well first of all i don't see
anything in here where we're supporting
another parent
that's a misnomer that's we get that
constantly
from people saying that i'm supporting
i'm giving a child support check and
supporting my wife
and that's not what it is
and to the other things that's what we
constantly hear from parents coming here
saying
um i can't afford a house because i'm
paying too much money i can't afford
a better vehicle because i'm paying too
much money you know so those are the
other things in the
original bill that the judges would
consider
um
and i think that would help
with
the payee
coming here stating
i you know i'm gonna eat beans
because i can't afford to eat
a hamburger
um you know so so the judge takes all of
that into consideration so removing
these other things i
i think hurts
um
with respect to um
finding the best
adaptive spot in both health for the
child i mean child support is having a
child living to the expectations so
if i make
250 000 a year and my ex-wife makes
40 000 a year my child's used to live in
a certain manner i'm going to anticipate
that
i'm going to be paying
heavily
to keep that child in um
you know in that adaptive uh
environment
um so
i i uh
personal experience well i'm on my third
wife so
uh
i guess my personal experience with
child scare too you know um you know so
you know i
i think leaving the other things in
there
i preferred that much better to have to
have the judge consider that may
consider that
you know because if it's
you know it has effect on a child
you know
uh
if i'm going to my dad's and i'm going
to sleep on a couch because he's paying
my mom too much money
then that ought to be a consideration
you know
so
any further discussion representative
baltshiller
turn it on you had it on
okay there we are
um so to be clear and um i
just in case there was any confusion
there is absolutely no intention
uh on my part in
making any kind of a case
that child support is for the benefit of
the parents child support is for the
benefit of the children and as we put in
statute
considering when the court shall
determine how to optimize use of the
parents combined incomes
to arrive at the best possible outcome
provided that the basic support needs of
the child or children are met so that is
exactly what we are talking about right
here
and um and in doing so it's important to
recognize that those children are under
the care and the custody of their
parents which is where they should be
and we want to support that as much as
possible
and that
setting up one of the parents for
failure
through
through legal
barriers is is antithetic to the what we
want to do to support children so i
would
i think that this amendment
um
[Music]
actually does it
does some damage to the
the original bill which we had worked so
very diligently on
um and
it takes out
you know costs of child rearing in
similar or appropriately equal styles so
[Music]
which speaks to what
representative long was saying and
my own personal experiences with child
support notwithstanding
we know
that in the state of new hampshire we
have children who are living in poverty
because
they have they are in homes that have
experienced
domestic violence
and experienced financial abuse
and this committee has heard a number of
testimonies to those exact
situations
and
keeps the children's interests in the
forefront
actually dials back
what is in the best interest of the
children and i urge my colleagues to not
support amendment 1575 and support
representative
thank you um so i wanted to just uh
a couple of of examples um one might be
that
the
parent
parent a has
um makes 250 000 a year and the parent b
makes 100 000 a year
so
there is no
there in those examples it may they may
not be struggling to provide
a household for the child but maybe and
so they would not qualify under lines 12
and 13 however maybe there are medical
bills or some other reason that it is in
the best interest of the child that this
um
formula be be used but that under the
unamended language that would not be
allowed to be taken not be allowed to be
done because it did not fall under both
situations and so i um
i
see where the um opposition is coming
from but i think that it's a
misunderstanding and that it is in fact
there are other reasons other than just
equalizing
the parent the the households that
should come into consideration and
actually the governing
thing should just be the best interest
of the child and there's nothing in the
um
in the language as written that
forbids the judge from considering
everything from line 12 to
um of the original bill that that can be
also assumed under the best interest of
the child if the court
believes that that is
something that they could consider
for the best interest of the child thank
you
representative altschiller
thank you madam chair for clarification
the original bill does cover health care
coverage costs on page two line one and
what we have learned from the testimony
particularly from new hampshire legal
assistance that we heard on april 12
that the enumerations
excuse me the enumerations of um that
which may be considered but not limited
to those variables that are outlined on
the original bill as amended by the
senate on lines 28 29 and of page one
and lines one and two of page two
give the examples for the courts because
the courts
have had difficulty
which is why we're here in determining
what those things are so we are actually
putting into place
that which is asked for
so again health care costs
right there in the original bill not in
also uninsured health care costs and
other child-related expenses so putting
one child in um a babysitting or daycare
situation while attending to the medical
needs of an another child who may be
hospitalized that's all covered here in
the first bill
as amended by the senate and is left out
representative ocala are we going to
debate all day or um until noon i think
that i felt like that was a good
stopping point no um i think that um
when i
uh i said
in my example i disagree with the um
the representative as far as them being
able to consider that thing because they
would have to stop at line 12 of the
amendment because if they if it did not
meet those qualifications they would not
be able to get into any other
adjustments the adjustment has to meet
the first two requirements and then the
judge's hands are tied and so i actually
argue that that is in fact not the case
that they would be able to deal with any
any adjustments on page two line one
because that would be part of an
adjustment assuming that they had
already ruled on the previous stuff that
was required um under
lines eight through twenty three so in
fact i completely disagree that they
would be able to make that adjustment so
discussion seeing then i'll have the
we're voting on ought to pass on the
amendment 1575.
representative desimone yes
representative yokela yes representative
nelson yes representative belanger yes
representative johnson
yes representative mcdonald yes
representative smith
representative long
no representative alessia
no representative grossman
no
representative levesque no
representative murray
no
representative
nope representative petrino i will be
voting no
madam chair rice
representative yokela do you now have a
motion yes i move out to pass as amended
is there a second second
seeing now and i'll have the clerk call
voting ought to pass
as amended
representative desimone yes
representative yo keller yes
representative nelson yes representative
belanger yes representative johnson yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative smith yes representative
long
no representative grossman
no representative levesque no
of representative murray no
representative
no
representative petrino votes
madam chair rice yes votes yes motion
not to pass as amended carries eight to
seven
someone's doing a major minority report
right
can we make sure i get those by the end
and
oh
out i'm keeping these
that's going out like the rock stuff i
am
wait a minute don't we have sessions oh
no it's thursday
we have a free day
oh
my grandfather
apologized i saw it was so cute
because i couldn't find anything
like with black
and i got tired of looking
oops
you